i'm in charge here the level of denial i
never said there was no massacre of
course there was a massacre
um to call it a massacre i'm not sure if
there is
a charge on the statute books
but you want to hang me
because i say this was not genocide you
want to hang me you want to crucify me
because i say this was not genocide
massive ethnic cleansing had been
carried out by the serbs
particularly against the the muslims the
praising of these war criminals
[Applause]
alhamdulillah we are in contract to
purchase this 35 000 square foot
facility to make it the dean center and
in it there will be a masjid inshallah
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind the prophet peace and blessings
be upon him said that the one who helps
build a masjid for allah allah will
build for them a house in jannah get the
tremendous rewards and donate right now
to help purchase this property may god
almighty allah reward all of you
[Music]
your host and my next guest robert
mcneil had a 40-year career in pathology
in scotland as a mortuary operations
manager in 1996 he volunteered to travel
to bosnia and herzegovina on behalf of
the physicians for human rights and the
international criminal tribunal for the
former yugoslavia to help gather
evidence against suspected perpetrators
indicted of war crimes crimes against
humanity and genocide as a forensic
technician he gathered evidence from the
victims bodies from hundreds of mass
graves
around srabanitsa and other parts of
bosnia and hefzegovina but also in
croatia in kosovo he carried out similar
work in africa thailand ireland and
france and in 1999 he was honored by
prince charles for his work
he has now written a book called grave
faces
about his work in bosnia
and kosovo and he's here with us how are
you doing robert
hello eddie thank you for inviting me
thank you very much for accepting the
invitation
so are you are you are you currently uh
residing in the uk
uh yes i i live in in glasgow in
scotland and that's where i'm speaking
to you from from my home
so tell me give us a very simple
understanding of the kind of work you're
an expert in starting from pathology to
the forensic
technician for the average person they
haven't heard these type of expertise
that you were involved in can you break
it down for us for the layman
yes well um uh i was uh as you say said
eddie i was the mortuary operations
manager
for covering all the mortuaries in in
glasgow and for uh for many years i
worked alongside the pathologists who
worked together very closely
establishing uh the causes of death at
autopsies
mainly from people who had died of
natural causes but also
in murder suicide and medical negligence
cases and so
i had a lot of experience
before being asked
to to go to the former yugoslavia to
start and as part of the first
international team of forensic
specialists including pathologists
anthropologists um police officers and
a radiographer from from all over the
world really uh and that's that's how i
ended up in in bosnia after being
invited by phr the charity based in in
boston who had appealed for forensic
specialists throughout the world
to volunteer to go to rwanda actually
initially
and i had volunteered to go there at
first until
i was contacted by phone to change my my
plans and instead to go out to bosnia
had you had much experience uh with
bosnia before have you ever visited
bosnia before did you know much about it
at all
no that's that's a good question eddie
uh i'm ashamed to say it now but
i had honestly never heard of bosnia i
knew all about the former yugoslavia and
the breakup of of of
the the six countries there
in early 1990s and um but gradually i
knew when i became aware of the
conflicts that were going on in in the
former yugoslavia bosnia was
increasingly being reported on in the
media and
all i knew about the former yugoslavia
was how beautiful a country it was and
that
tourism was one of the main industries
and so and certainly from
people in europe would often travel
there
on vacation and so that was about as
much as i knew um
i had been reading up on excuse me
the
bigger pardon i've been reading up on
the history of the genocide in rwanda
and i was quite clear on on what i was
going to be doing there but i have to
say that um the war in bosnia seemed to
be so complicated um that i i left it
until i went out there uh to try and
learn from myself exactly what had
happened
over the the the previous couple of
years
where of course
slobodan milosevic the president of
serbia uh had decided to carve up
um the the former countries and the the
balkans and create a greater serbia
and
countries in the former yugoslavia
decided
differently that they wanted to be
independent countries and and
run them themselves
so tell me now when you got there you
get on the ground what's the feeling
like what are you saying describe to us
as soon as you get there what's going
through your mind your body your soul
yeah well we we we arrived eventually
arrived
in zagreb in croatia
and were taken by by vehicle
down through croatia
and crossed into bosnia and almost
immediately there were clear signs of
the war
in fact
we had to stop at one point at a a gas
station
to fill up the vehicle and
the u.n driver pointed to a poll that
had been stuck in the ground where uh he
explained that that
muslims had been impaled in those polls
in order to prevent them
from entering those particular areas
because
i had learned that massive ethnic
cleansing had been carried out by the
serbs
particularly against the the muslims
and there was many many signs of
destroyed buildings uh uh
not only destroyed but had been
surrounded with mines and uh and
apparently uh we were told that the the
servers would
throw grenades into the house and uh in
order to blow the roof the roofs off
them um
and just completely destroy them to make
them
uninhabitable but as we drove further
into bosnia and we're becoming more and
more aware of the destruction we began
to see refugees um i should explain that
this was in 1996 shortly after the date
necro
accord and people were trying to find
their way home or indeed to find
somewhere else to live and so the the
roads were were full of of poor people
who had obviously suffered
and where what struck me
um
eddie was when i i saw people living in
buildings with no roofs on them and the
frontage of the the buildings had been
been destroyed and it was a surreal
sight because people were cooking on
fires and children were playing with
toys and so on um
and it reminded me actually of a a child
playing with a doll's house except that
it was so awful
and the other thing that we noticed
quite often in our drive down there was
that uh religious buildings in
particular mosques had been totally
destroyed um by by the serbs
um and i learned later that this was a a
way of
trying to destroy not only the muslim
population but their culture and
religious uh places as well
and so when we arrived in
the the city of tuslav where we were
going to be based
um we were we were abilitied with
various local people who'd volunteered
to
to to to let us live in their homes
while we went out to
the mass graves and um and
i i i soon realized that you could
hardly find a single person
in the city who hadn't been
affected by the by the war um the couple
we lived with
two women a mother and daughter
were waiting
um
in vain i should say for
the women's husband and the daughter's
father to return home he had
been in srebrenica and the family were
told it would be questioned and then
sent
sent out of srebrenica to the next safe
area which was tusla
and i find it very sad that each night
she would set a dinner plate a service a
dinner service uh empty set uh plate
for her husband the hope that he would
return home and
certainly while we were there he never
did and so that was my my first reaction
was one of great sadness about the
suffering that
people had had
experienced uh toosler as well of course
wasn't um you know wasn't exempt from
the horrors
because there was much destruction of
the structure there so you pretty much
traveled through the whole country
more or less from from zagreb directly
down to tuesday
it was quite a long drive and as i say
in a way i'm i'm glad i did that there
was no flights available at that time
because the
um the the un and their so-called wisdom
had created a no-fly zone and so this of
course had a major effect of those
people who had been ethnically cleansed
to escape the country
because um all passenger flights had
been cancelled and so they they were
left to their own devices for a long
time
the areas uh the the the huge numbers of
people being ethnically cleansed i mean
eventually there were up to two million
people trying to find a sanctuary and
another
thing that
the un did to try and
help i suppose but it wasn't really much
help was to create safe areas six safe
areas had been created
in bosnia um where those who had been
ethnically cleansed uh were told that
they should go there and that they would
be protected
um
and i should say it's quite important to
say this because the word area when
described as a safe area
puzzled me because
why did they call it a safe haven if
they were going to protect those people
and the answer is that they didn't want
to commit themselves to
fighting against the serbs and so this
made up this word through many meetings
about how they could describe it
these places and they called it
safaris which really meant nothing at
all
and the mandate behind that that the un
had was not to fight for the the muslim
population or fight against the serbs um
it was really to observe
first of all um and to provide
humanitarian aid for those areas because
the population of srebrenica one of the
the first safe areas
had been around something like 7 000
mainly muslim people and that had grown
to over 30 000 people
almost all have having nowhere to live
and the humanitarian aid was a pitiful
failure as well because uh we learned
that
the
the convoys of food and medical aid that
was being sent to those areas
uh there was a price
to pay to the serbs to allow them
through
um and that meant that the serbs would
search each convoy each truck uh and on
the belief or or in the
the the story they gave was that was to
search for weapons and they didn't want
weapons to be provided and the price
they charged the un for that was to take
up to a third of the the contents of the
trucks and these aids were stopped in
numerous times with the same price to
pay and so by the time they reached
srebrenica and other safe areas there
was very little left for the population
who
were held under siege for up to three
years and that included at least two
winters
so your job if i'm correct if i
understood
is to come on the sea now uh and to
identify help families identify
their bodies help put pieces together to
understand how a person actually died
what happened to this individual amongst
other things is this
correct
well
almost our job uh was simply the the
brief that we were given by the
international criminal tribunal was to
gather evidence from after carrying out
meticulous autopsies on each victim
to provide evidence physical and
scientific evidence to for the
prosecutors to produce in core i see
yeah identification
was something that we weren't asked to
do however of course
anything that we could do to help with
the identification process we would
this was in 1996 and and dna matching at
that time
wasn't really available
clothing that was on victims
couldn't be used as primary
identification because as i said there
were people who'd been under siege for
so long that the clothing could have
belonged to anyone someone may have died
and passed on
those clothes and um but nevertheless
the clothing was a helpful indication
uh it's important to note that
all the women who were
who were expelled from from srebrenica
uh they had to find their way to tusla
the next safe area and raccoon laddich
the military commander had assured them
that the men would be taken for
questioning and it would be with them
soon so the women and certainly when
when i was there
many of them
they didn't make us unwelcome but they
didn't want to hear that their loved
ones were dead they still believed that
they were alive and would be returning
home at any time
but gradually um they they would arrive
at the temporary mortuary gates
looking for any
information about them and it was
heartbreaking um
to tell them that at this stage we
couldn't identify the bodies properly
and that might take
some time
and of course it took many years for the
identification but
but we did of course gather as much
evidence
on that first deployment as possible but
there were many interruptions um
mainly from the media because it was a
major international story at the time
but also um
there were those whose in whose
interests it might be
to um to disrupt our work and and at one
point we had to
abandon the temporary mortuary because
we were under threat so
uh so we carried on with the work
who are you under threats from
well from the serbs um because although
the
the the war had
effectively stopped uh there was
sporadic fighting still going on and
um
and the the military uh
uh informed us that this they had
intelligence to say that they were going
to try and prevent us from doing our
work and we assumed that that meant uh
violence and so uh we had to abandon
watchfully for a few days until we got
proper full security uh when after that
we could carry on
but that was a feature certainly in the
early days um of of deployment to
tuesday
um in 1997
uh i had i should say that when i
returned home to scotland um i was quite
depressed because we hadn't really
achieved very much
the the post-mortem the autopsies had to
be carried out meticulously we couldn't
make any mistakes because we knew
um that would be high-profile
people who had been indicted for these
crimes and they would have
some pretty good
defense lawyers et cetera
and at the same time
bodies were coming in all the time from
the graves which were
being discovered uh you know
quite often and i decided uh in 95 sorry
96 after that first trip that i would
return there the following year
um
and
when i returned there i
committed more time out there this time
to try and carry on with the victims
from srebrenica
however once again there were
interruptions um
there were bodies being discovered in
mass graves in the theodore area
where the serbs had created a number of
concentration camps including
the the notorious omarska uh turnopoly
and keraterm camps and
we learned up to 150 men and women were
being tortured and murdered uh and
thrown into mass graves in those places
and so we've been pulled in different
directions to deal with
with those those bodies and uh on top of
that there was a a nato uh chinook
helicopter crash uh in the vicinity uh
and that that the passengers they were
high profile military uh
nato uh people um and from different
countries and
we were asked to deal to identify those
bodies
as well
but the worst um delay came from
a different source which turned out to
be particularly awful for the victims
families
we were told that during the winter
graves that hadn't we hadn't secured
had been re-entered by the serbs the
bodies these were the primary graves the
bodies were then removed
torn apart using mechanical diggers and
those body parts were then distributed
in much harder places to find
for further into republic of serbs
and so as i said the the families must
have been completely devastated by this
because by now by 1997
um they they had began to believe that
their men were dead and all they wanted
uh was to have their bodies returned to
them for a decent burial
instead of the eight and a half thousand
men and boys from srebrenica we were now
uh faced with up to 17 000 body parts
many of those body parts had been buried
in multiple secondary graves
in the belief as i say that we would
never find them and if we did we would
never be able to put them together again
or indeed identify them
and in that score
they were wrong
because the the icty decided to up the
ante as far as personnel were concerned
and
i was relieved to learn that
forensic specialists from up to 32
countries worldwide
were
able to provide
many more forensic specialists to carry
on with the work because
um this this job we all knew was going
to take years and
and i returned there every year up until
2001 when by which time the icty had
more than enough
evidence to to prosecute those who were
charged
tell me robert
how long did it take for the
international community to confirm that
this was indeed a genocide and genocide
as we know by some definitions the
deliberate killing of a large number of
people
or a particular nation group with the
aim of destroying this nation or group
how long did it take
for you to be convinced as an expert for
the international community to confirm
that indeed this was a great this was a
genocide and is the statement true that
this was the greatest genocide that was
committed
since the
war since world war ii
yeah
yeah well um
as a as a forensic technician indeed all
of the specialists
we we're trained to be completely
objective in our work um in fact i had
worked with
cert victims and croatian victims
who had been killed as part of the wars
there
and
but what struck me uh working with the
the in particular the muslims from
uh from frebenitsa and those from
preadore
was the the brutality that was meted out
against them um
in srebrenica for example
many of the men and boys had been
badly beaten their hands tied behind
their backs and blindfolded
so it was clear
that this was at the very least war
crimes because these men and boys were
mainly civilians um
and
and when i tried to be objective uh i
found that sometime most of us found
this sometimes challenging because of
the nature of the
of the deaths and
it's the up to the courts of course to
decide um you know what the the judgment
would be regarding the category of crime
um i personally believed although i'm
not qualified to say it that
that that that
milosevic and karedan maladic had
focused on the muslim population in
particular
they used that as a
as a weapon of war if you like um
because this war
in the west was being described as a
civil war of of um
people fighting one another they've been
doing it for centuries and so on uh i
personally came to the conclusion after
working there uh on
hundreds if not thousands of bodies
that this was a war of aggression
against uh
people who believed in in islam and
and followed that faith and uh so
one of the things that surprised me i
guess
eddie was when the judgments finally
came against the main perpetrators uh
unfortunately milosevic as you probably
know died whilst he was on trial but
kharidich and maladic and kirstich and
others um
they were the the architects of this it
was clear that the muslim population
were being targeted uh they were being
forced out of of europe
basically i think that was that was the
plan
um
what disturbed me a wee bit i guess was
that uh
the the the the charges of genocide
against the main perpetrators was
limited
to srebrenica which was absolutely
correct and to some extent
in sarajevo because of what was
happening there
i know and i have friends for example in
the preador area we were very very upset
when the same charge wasn't handed out
about the deaths
in the camps and indeed in other parts
of bosnia
i remember at the time that the judges
ruling that they would explain their
judgment
later on uh and i've never heard what
that explanation was but um
and so
at the time when when the the guilty
charges were passed on
uh on karadike meladic in particular
there was sadness plus cheering um
particularly
around the portachary area where the
beautiful cemetery now is
that contains um
over six thousand of the the men and
boys from srebrenica and from other
parts of bosnia
but in portugal there was sadness great
sadness and they feel they felt a bit
led down i mean the guilty charges were
were bad enough it was war crimes crimes
against humanity and many other
charges also including
multiple rape and
you know that too was
what was disturbing and that
up to 50 000 mainly muslim women who are
systematically raped
in in bosnia
in an attempt to humiliate them and
sadly many of those women
died or committed suicide they were
forced to take their pregnancies to full
term
and that you know caused mayhem you know
in families and so on so it was
it was a dreadful
time and
but it did at least establish that rape
was indeed a war crime and could form
part of a genocide
in future and
but that doesn't help those who who
suffered
during that time
i want to get your
thoughts and expert reaction from
someone who spent time on the ground
there and was a key figure here
in bosnia so i want to share something
with you
and get your
thoughts on this
okay but you will not accept that they
are sorry no i don't want to hear
anything more i've heard your question
i'm answering you yes
thank you i've heard your question let
me answer you
i'm fed up
[Music]
what i said was
that this was not genocide
i didn't say it was not a massacre
let me speak please
let me sleep please
i'm in charge here
i never said there was no massacre of
course there was a massacre
but you want to hang me
because i say this was not genocide you
want to hang me you want to crucify me
because i say this was not genocide
i said there was a massacre
i said all these muslims were killed i
know who did it but you don't know
i know who did it you don't know
on judgement day you will know so is is
it enough now this is a um
a
a person by the name of imran hussein
respectfully
you know we just wanted to show this
he's uh
he's a specialist in the area of
eschatology
and he's a well-known figure
he's also traveled down there with
we assume good intentions to try to
bring and this is something we commend
you know good relations between orthodox
christians muslims very commendable but
in this area
is this sufficient to say it was a mass
massacre and to deny that it was a
genocide
that this was not genocide
i didn't say it was not a massacre
what are your thoughts on that
well as i say i'm i'm not a lawyer and
i'm certainly not a judge but
i think that the evidence that was
provided to the icty to the prosecution
clearly alongside witnesses witness
evidence uh showed that yes there were
thousands of people killed
now it's
it's
one explanation to call it a massacre
but the judges and they were
international judges i should say
came to the conclusion
that to prove
genocide is the most difficult
charge to prove really because they have
to show evidence that this was planned
it was against a particular group of
people
and that those plans to a great extent
had been carried out
so
as far as the the evidence that we
provided as i said earlier eddie um
there were experts from including from
america i must say some of the most
eminent experts in the world had
traveled there to provide the evidence
uh
that that i can't believe that
that people will say that um
that that
the evidence that was provided was
inaccurate or wrong
but it's hard to for us to see you know
what whether it constituted a genocide
or not but i firmly believe that that
many of us believed that this was a
systematic
destruction of a particular population
that were easy targets really um and
people that couldn't defend themselves
the un didn't help by creating an arms
embargo where the the serbs and the
croats had
huge armies and had plenty of weapons
the the the the the bosniaks didn't have
an army at all and the the weaponry
that they had to defend themselves was
often world war ii rifles and so on and
so
um this was mainly a civilian population
that were
systematically
uh destroyed and uh uh and i understand
why people um would challenge the the
the court rulings uh but
um they are there and uh
as i said earlier it would take an awful
lot
of evidence for the judges to agree on a
charge of genocide and
one of the things that disturbs me and
why i wrote
this book was
um
that genocide denial is is rampant just
now in republic of
in particular
and in serbia
as is the glorification of the war
criminals
there's a whole gamut of
explanations as to why people deny
and i understand that but
the genocide genocide denial that's
going on just now is so dangerous
the people in
the muslims and republic of serbs gun in
bosnia
are now terrified that because the the
the leaders of republic of serbs go want
to secede from bosnia um and that could
stir up another war and um
and so i believe that what we should be
doing is challenging the genocide denial
um to call it a massacre i'm not sure if
there is
a charge on the statute books
that
people can be prosecuted for a massacre
it was quite clear what the
the rules were the the the terms were
wide and varied but the main ones really
were war crimes crimes against humanity
and and genocide but in between
um those that were they were perhaps
call them lesser crimes but
uh you know mentioned um sexual abuse
and so on but there were many crimes
that put together
could uh be argued i guess
that this was a deliberate attempt to
rid a part of europe from the muslim
population
just to touch upon this also before we
get deeper into your book
and hopefully god willing
we call our elders sheikh so imran
hussein he can make a change for the
better because he has a voice and a lot
of people listen to him so hopefully him
listening to this and hearing you and
hopefully he can change may have a
change of heart maybe come down to visit
bosnia
and get on the ground and talk to the to
the people and the scholars there and
people like yourself but he also
mentions how there's a deep regret
you know that's one of the
reasons why he also
makes this decision
and they tell me that they are sorry for
what happened
but
you mentioned the
war criminals being paraded in most
cases i've seen where they have stadiums
where people are chanting ratklo maddich
and these other war criminals in
belgrade
they are angry that the bosnian serb
wartime general ratco maladic has been
arrested
[Music]
many came by bus from across the country
for the evening rally in the serbian
capital
for them mladic is a hero a defender of
the serb people
the 69 year old has been indicted for
genocide over the siege of sarajevo and
the massacre of 8 000 muslim men and
boys in srebrenica support for alleged
war criminal radco mladic isn't
restricted to serbia fans of the former
army chief were out on the streets of
pala in bosnia-herzegovina on thursday
night the town was the administrative
center of the breakaway republica
serbska during the bosnian war people
were also showing their support in the
former capital banya luka
[Applause]
conserves gathered in the eastern town
of baillinia on thursday to voice their
support for ratko mladic and their anger
at serbian president boris taraj
many of the protesters carried serbian
flags and photos of mladic who they
regard as a war hero rather than
criminal
and these are these are not like 10 15
people this is like i always compare it
to imagine if you had a whole stadium
and people are like chanting for daesh
or isis some of these radical uh
extreme groups
and then the government did nothing
about it and they let them go on
so what kind of regret is that that's
that's uh seems like a hypocrisy so
let's touch upon that i mean so you've
seen that you've seen where the the
praising of these war criminals
uh that
happens uh yearly i believe is that is
that correct
yeah kind of the commemoration of uh
people such as radical modes the butcher
and and the others yeah that you
mentioned yeah that's very sad it's very
sad to see that i i i'm bewildered like
how do you praise people like this it's
like people praising hitler or whatnot
yeah yeah that's absolutely right and
every time there is an anniversary of
um a terrible event for example
uh in
um uh white armband day for example
there's recognition of that in in
certainly in the uk um and this
represents where uh where people from
north eastern bordeaux
bosnia
where were
evicted from their homes the serbs had
uh told everyone every non-serb to wear
a white armband and hang white sheets
from their homes and you know you can
relate this going back to the holocaust
and what happened to the jewish people
where they had to identify them um as
non-serbs and uh and there's been great
denial
from serbia about that they said it
never happened and
um i've actually spoken to
members of bosniaks who suffered
that experience and
um and i don't know if you can see the
painting behind me but uh that is about
a typical family being evicted from
their homes
wearing white armbands and behind them
is the concentration camp
where
the woman's husband was incarcerated so
so there is great denial about that
in july 11th um
every year
the serbs and certainly those in
republic of serbs
um celebrates that that that event where
up to eight and a half thousand men boys
help me on so say that again repeat
repeat that what you just said so every
july 11th that's when the
and who celebrates what
well the the
the serbs
of some serves not all of them but um
particularly those in republic of serbs
uh hold rallies and they celebrate the
fact that miladic had taken srebrenica
for the third population whilst at the
same time there is um
the the there is memorials and
commemorations going on throughout
bosnia and certainly in the uk
um to to to commemorate the deaths
in in srebrenica and in other parts of
bosnia um and of course there are
muslims who live in republic of serbs
who
brave people who return to their own
homes um
who are having to witness that
i know that for example
a friend of mine whose
uh uncle and brother were murdered by
the serbs
on july 11th
when he eventually got his his father
and brother's body returned to them
by the icty uh for burial along with
i can't remember exactly how but there
was up to 600 people being buried in
portugal
on that day
and he describes how when carrying the
coffin
along the streets of srebrenica uh there
was lines of people on either side
and bearing in mind it's
as part of republic of serps
who were taunting them spitting on them
and so on and abusing them really was
this young man was simply trying to bury
his his loved ones and and this happened
to all of the people there and um and
you have to be very careful when going
to srebrenica itself about what you see
and who you see it to
because there is a rawness um
about those who
have been accused of of war crimes and
many of them uh particularly police
officers uh
who are responsible for this are back on
duty again and it's it's quite
threatening back on duty again many of
them oh yes
this is what uh sheikh is saying he
should go to republic of scotland we
invite him he should come down and go
ahead come to the bosnia and have them
take him there and i actually i went to
speak to a
a
commander
in the republican serbs can army he's
older gentlemen he was
with the likes of some of these uh
individuals i went to his church
actually you can see the video
in front of the orthodox church
yeah honor your father and your mother
um
and love your neighbor
as us we have to deliver the message of
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the creator allah we have to do that
with compassion with love but i say to
you
hear love your enemies do good to those
who hate you yes
i can go to the hell fire god will
punish me if i say one bad thing of
jesus
in islam says that we also worship one
and only one god
yes
reading an article where you said
uh correct me if i'm wrong
did you ever hear or study the life of
prophet muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him so out of his love and mercy he
sent messengers
and they all came with the same message
and they all came with the same message
for human beings to submit their will to
the one god and i would also i would
sincerely humbly i would request that
you look more into the life of the last
and final messenger sent to mankind
prophet muhammad who came with the same
message as
jesus calling people to la illahi
there's nothing worthy of worship but
the one god and muhammad is the
messenger so we would say if you had the
old testament new testament the quran is
the last and final testament
when you have deliberate attempts of
denial praising commemorating you know
such criminals
[Applause]
[Music]
uh then
how how can you move forward and then
you have another side here
who
are do do we see others from who are
are they a minority who will um
accept this as something evil that
happened to go ahead and come against
because as a muslim i will condemn any
other muslim who uses
kills innocent people this is something
forbidden in islam and we would condemn
that the killing of innocent men women
and children clearly and i don't uh shy
away from that do we have other others
out there who will go ahead and come
against these uh techniques and others
these uh extremists to go ahead and try
to protest
these
um commemorations like you had mentioned
that happen
yeah well
the last time i was i've been back to
bosnia um mainly uh on behalf of the
charity remembering srebrenica uk
um and i've i've taken
people all individuals from various
faiths and educators and so on
uh to to bosnia to for them to learn the
story themselves and to meet the people
who were affected by it
and we always try uh to to meet with
some of the the mothers of srebrenica
that's a a group who set up
um to try and a find the their loved
ones and um
and they often are at the cemetery to
relate their sad stories um to to the
visitors and i remember asking one of
the the mothers
or somebody asked
do you forgive the the serbs for what
they had done
um and her answer was very poignant i
thought she said that
well we've never been asked for
forgiveness
um and perhaps
if we if we were asked to forgive by the
the people uh uh responsible
perhaps they would
they would do it um that was they they
they may not forgive but they will never
forget no matter whether they forgive
them
that's powerful she said that they never
asked for forgiveness so how could we
forgive
yes they never asked for forgiveness so
how could we could forgive yeah wow
which underlines the the
the denial the level of denial that's
being um that's been portrayed uh where
as i say new generations have have grown
up
since uh what happened in bosnia there's
there's
i think three versions of history been
taught in the schools
and of course the serbian
educators talk about denial as well and
that they try to justify the actions
there so so to say you're getting young
people who are growing up with with
um not naturally
totally different uh stories of of the
the truth and yeah and that's quite
disturbing as well yeah so how can you
grow then if you don't admit the mistake
if you don't um ask for forgiveness how
are you and you deny it then you're
probably on your way to possibly do it
again right yeah so that's why it's
important you said here your your
july 11th is coming up
so my next question is
uh why is it important to not forget
what had happened and tell us what you
go into
in your book your book
that
grave faces uh before you answer that
you were going to say something please
oh yes i i was i was going to say eddie
that um that many of the people
who
who suffered um i think
uh they appreciate the fact that uh that
people from europe and abroad uh you
know i've taken some americans there and
of course uh um
many specialists work there um
the the the population are at least
grateful maybe that's not the right word
of outsiders coming to learn what
happened there um and i think part of it
is that because they felt so abandoned
at the time by the politicians in the
west and allowed
episodes like srebrenica and many other
atrocities to to continue
throughout the early 90s
and uh i'm part of an ambassador for for
remembering shreveports the uk as a say
and uh and i think that uh people like
myself and other experts who
who who witness the the level of cruelty
and barbarity meted against the mainly
muslim population um can
help people
as i say educators and different faiths
and so on i'll be a bit late but
nevertheless i know that the population
uh are very grateful to the people are
interested at last people are interested
in what i would like to see is for
um for other countries in the world
to recognize and to
hold a memorial in july or whenever
in order to remember them because
my understanding is that the uk is the
only country in the world that has
regular
um commemorations of the the the
srebrenica genocide and the the war
crimes and so on that happened
throughout bosnia and in fact next week
uh i'll be going to the uh the
house houses of parliament and the
foreign office who will commemorate
because it's reached
you know government level where they
nationally we recognize
what happened and also the failures that
were um
by the west and and not preventing this
this terrible war to escalate
yeah
yeah we just got a few more minutes left
uh yeah like you said you had like you
started off in the beginning it's like i
call you over i say hey i got your back
i'm going to take care of you i'm going
to give you a safe haven a safe zone and
then you have the whole dutch battalion
they take off and actually let this
happen is very sad it's very sad and uh
i went there i saw it was like u.n and
had under there
yes
i said united nothing
because they did they did nothing
so i i toured there it was very sad um
tell me uh your book your book gray
faces uh
tell us uh
in that book
you talk about many of things we're
discussing and what else do you
highlight in this book and why is it so
important that people who want to know
more that they they read and get
educated
on this and your book is a great
resource grave faces tell us more about
it
um
well i kept a diary uh for um
many of the deployments that i went to
wow so you actually kept a dart while
things are happening this is live you're
you're recording wow
each night i i i would spend an hour uh
writing up what i'd done that day i mean
it would be very boring to most people
and but nevertheless um
it was after i retired actually i
decided that uh this whole battered
school jorter um could be turned into a
manuscript because
i was part of the remembering frederica
organization then
and it occurred to me that
um that people might be interested in
the story for a couple of reasons one
the forensic side of it the fact that um
we went out there in 1996
and it was really just a learning
experience because no one had been
involved in anything like this before
but we learned very quickly and those
protocol protocols that we wrote after
that first deployment
we improved on through time and by the
end 2001 um it was a pretty smooth
operation i must say
and a very successful one became the
the biggest uh forensic investigation in
history and it's arguable that it was
the most successful because many people
feel let down because the perpetrators
of their crime or their families crimes
hadn't been uh hadn't been dealt with um
and so
also i mentioned genocide denial i felt
that it might be something that could be
used uh to to challenge those who who
who deny what happened there but i also
write about my personal experience with
the bosniaks that i encountered there we
lived with
as i said earlier with with local people
um both in tuesday and in visaco
where we set up a proper mortuary there
um and all of them
all of those peoples had suffered and it
was heartbreaking listening to their
stories uh and i wanted to to write
about them because
i know unbiased um eddie but uh uh i
fell in love with bosnia and the bosnian
bosniak people uh they were so welcoming
even although they had very little they
would share it with us
and
i've found that very moving and since
then i've made a number of friends
uh that
protocol friends who we we still
communicate with the
so i wanted to recognize them
and i also write about some of the quite
eccentric characters that i work with
you know
forensic pathologists
are lovely people but occasionally you
come across
experts who have always had their own
way in their own
universities or or facilities and it was
often a challenge for them to adapt to
the quite spartan conditions that we
worked in
and there was a hope an element of humor
as well because it you know it you
couldn't
we had to do the job it was depressing
it was the place smelled awful all the
time and uh and in the early days
food was was sparse
um and it it was
we had to become a family of our own i
guess you know because many of us were
away from home for quite long times and
so uh so we turned to one another for
help and support and to see a wee bit of
humor could be injected into that as
well
um
and so
i wanted to write various aspects of the
book in particular
about what happened to
in the concentration camps and
um and
the sexual abuse that was carried out in
those camps against both women and men
i must say because we were asked to look
for evidence of
sexual assault in
in men male victims and so
i just wanted to try and tell as much of
the story that i had recorded um and
turned it into a book that i'm proud to
say that
bihar publication for publishing have
have now published this book
i want to
commend you god bless you for all of
your
amazing efforts that you've put forward
and people can go ahead and benefit from
grave faces
so where can people pick this book up
i believe it's available um in america
now
[Music]
has showed me a photograph of boxes of
books so i believe it may be available
on amazon amazon
yeah i think so could i just add one
thing yes please we go please and um i i
made up my mind a long time ago uh that
i wouldn't feel comfortable about
profiting financially from anything i do
i'm an artist now as well and i've been
many paintings about bosnia and my
experiences there but as far as the book
is concerned um i'm donating all of the
proceeds from me to the
it's a wonderful organization run by a
woman a very brave woman called bakira
hassasic from
from vishagrad actually but her
organization which is called
the association of women victims of war
and bakira and her staff uh continually
support
uh women who have been so have suffered
serious sexual abuse um not just muslims
but mainly muslims
throughout the war and bakira herself
has has a life
commitment to tracking down rapists who
were um who were never
convicted and exposing them and so she's
an extraordinarily brave woman
some of them like you said who've got
their old jobs back
yeah exactly god bless you thank you so
much i was honored talking to you robert
god bless you and
god willing we can maybe meet sometime
in the future in bosnia
i hope so i hope so eddie it's been a
pleasure thanks very much for
highlighting it thank you very much
right we'll be in touch thank you
thank you assalamu alaikum everyone
greetings of peace as you know there is
so much misinformation being spread
about islam and muslims by the hate
machine by the islamophobia industry
that manipulates the masses and creates
this manufactured fear and the fear
leads to hate and we know where the hate
leads that's where the dean center comes
in masjid athletic facility recording
studio live events open houses public
relations educating our brothers and
sisters in humanity being a voice for
the voiceless and the good news is we
are halfway to our goal and we need your
help prayers into ours so we can get the
other half closed on the property in
september inshallah god willing the rest
will be paid off inshallah over three
years owner financing no interest time
is taking brothers and sisters be a part
of history help make this a reality do
your part donate right now